[Música]
es el incidente que más muertes ha
dejado en Irán desde las protestas que
empezaron a mediados de septiembre la
policía abrió Fuego contra la multitud
tras la oración del viernes y según los
informes oficiales al menos 70 personas
murieron pero el número real de víctimas
podría ser mucho mayor el hecho ocurrió
en sage dan capital de la provincia de
sistán y paluchistán en el sureste de
Irán cerca de la frontera con Pakistán y
Afganistán a pesar del corte parcial de
internet en la ciudad decenas de videos
aficionados aparecieron estos muestran
una violencia y una violenta represión
en varias partes de la ciudad
con la ayuda de testigo se reconstruimos
la secuencia de los hechos en Irán ha
habido grandes protestas desde la muerte
de maxam Mini de 22 años que murió tras
ser detenida por la policía de la moral
por no cubrirse el cabello
[Aplausos]
las mujeres iraníes tuvieron un papel
destacado en las protestas de saquedán
como en otras ciudades de Irán poniendo
sus Preocupaciones en el centro de la
reivindicaciones pero en sitán y va a
lucistán hay otras cuestiones en juego
esta provincia más pobre de Irán hogar
de La minoría sunny palucci que se
siente abandonada y también oprimida
económicamente recientemente las
tensiones aumentaron tras las
acusaciones de que el jefe de la policía
del puerto de trabajar había violado una
joven balucci de 15 años afirmaciones
que aún no se han confirmado
exageran todo empezó aquí en amosella el
principal lugar de culto de la ciudad
cuando terminó la oración del viernes
justo enfrente de la estación de policía
número 16 nuestro observador Mohamed
estaba allí transcribimos su testimonio
para proteger su identidad
sabíamos que iba a haber una protesta
después de la oración del viernes en
varios grupos en redes sociales se había
hecho un llamado al respecto al final de
las oraciones muchas personas se
reunieron frente a la musalla la gente
empezó a acercarse la estación de
policía algunos solo seguían la multitud
otro realmente querían Mostrar su ira
los manifestantes empezaron a lanzar
piedras contra la estación de policía
algunos entraron a la fuerza la policía
primero disparó al aire y luego comenzó
a dispararle a la gente con munición
Real no solo los manifestantes
sino también a las personas que
simplemente estaban ahí Mirando algunas
resultaron heridas y muertas
el cuerpo a lo que parece ser un niño
fue grabado a 150 metros de la estación
de policía los videos aficionados
también muestran decenas de Muertos
heridos en el lugar de la oración las
heridas sugieren haber sido causadas por
disparos de armas automáticas
[Música]
las manifestaciones se extendieron
entonces a una zona más grande de la
ciudad una de las calles principales
estaba llena de manifestantes que
cantaban y lanzaban piedras
una vez más la respuesta de la policía
fue disparar munición Real contra la
población Y una vez más matar a muchas
personas los manifestantes también
tomaron represalias incendiaron una base
de la milicia
rama para militar de la Poderosa Guardia
revolucionaria islámica
y también incendiaron patrullas de la
policía
tras el atardecer la policía tomó las
calles se impuso un toque de queda sin
previo aviso en la ciudad
les disparaban a todos los que veían sin
importar porque estuvieran en la calle
me dispararon tres veces cuando solo
intentaba llegar a mi casa
la ong amnistía internacional documentó
la muerte y al menos 70 personas en
sagedán en ese día según los medios de
comunicación estatales entre los muertos
hay cuatro policías los manifestantes
fueron calificados de terroristas y se
difundieron imágenes de supuestas armas
en manos de los manifestantes
según testigos que participaron en estas
manifestaciones policías vestidos de
civil también dispararon contra la
multitud aquel día las autoridades
trataron de limitar el acceso a internet
en la ciudad pero el número de personas
asesinadas sería la luz entre ellos
están mojamab rayajiní de 12 años sadid
ka shanni de 14 y biomith safarge sí de
17 como muchos habitantes mohama se
pregunta por qué murió tanta gente está
claro que tenían órdenes de matar y que
no les temían a las consecuencias ese es
el problema estamos en la provincia de
sistán y baluchistán y pensaron que
nadie se preocuparía por nuestras vidas
por eso no tenían o no utilizaron armas
letales para hacer retroceder a la gente
ni siquiera utilizaron casos
lacrimógenos como hacen las fuerzas de
seguridad en Teherán hispagán estoy
seguro de que si tuvieran este tipo de
armas no letales mayoría de las personas
que fueron asesinadas seguirían vivas
hoy
hasta aquí esta historia documentada con
nuestros observadores en Irán Si desea
estar al tanto de nuestras noticias en
imágenes aficionados que documentamos en
Irán o en otros lugares vayan a nuestro
sitio web y todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla hace una próxima
oportunidad